they came to march through central new
delhi but were blocked and pushed back
by hundreds of police officers
despite being forced to stay on one road
people taking part in the so-called
citizens march said they wouldn't be
deterred from showing their solidarity
with protesting farmers
on the outskirts of the capital whatever
the government may think of the farmers
demands the fact that you
use repression that you fire on farmers
you use tear gas shells you use
patents the last time they were on delhi
streets and now you are
actually assembling this entire army
outside their protest
sites the number of security forces at
protest sites has increased
since violence broke out between some
protesters and police on republic day
last week
police have erected rows of barriers
around the sites using concrete and
steel barricades
barbed wire and stone boulders water
electricity and internet services have
intermittently been cut off
and police have also taken action
against journalists
mandip punia was detained after he
reported on a large group of people who
were throwing stones at protesters in
the area of
his wife has accused the police of
harassment
what sort of system is this where a
journalist who is doing his job with
great loyalty is being targeted
they strategically target and profile
him and file such
charges against him and mentally harass
him for the next 24 hours
and they weren't just targeting him but
the entire journalist community
members of the bharatiya janta party and
the government's chief lawyer have
also blamed the protests on six
separatists despite
a lack of evidence it has been a pattern
over the last few years
that they have begun to weaponize
sedation laws weaponize anti-terror laws
against dissenters they do not recognize
the simple fact that when you have a
public protest
it is being done in a manner which
doesn't really need a conspiracy
people in new delhi are also protesting
against the police charging farm leaders
with sedition
rioting and attempt to murder following
last week's protests
despite all of the arrests and charges
many more farmers are traveling from
their villages and states around delhi
to join the protests
and people have come out here in the
capital to show their support
elizabeth paranam al jazeera new delhi